Ok, empezaremos entonces. Antes de empezar, voy a ver las listas y voy a tomar asistencia ya.
Y aquí ya estamos finalizando el curso, así que los últimos cuatro clases que nos queda,
voy a tratar de llamar lista para ver quiénes son sobrevividos y que
ya.
Ya, en base a lo que me han presentado a sus compañeros, la lista,
ahorita les voy a mostrar la lista oficial, listo? Si alguien falta,
puede decirme, pero en este caso voy a mostrar los extenabilitados directamente para esta
segunda fase. Los que tienen más de cinco o seis faltas ya están eliminados, pero no
ustedes, no son esos creo, así que los 16 oficiales que quedan son los siguientes.
Ahora dame el ratito.
Ya sé, dame el ratito chicos.
Ya.
Listo, son ellos ya, son los 16 que tengo en lista y con eso en base eso vamos a tratar de llamar
lista el día de hoy, listo? Así que empezaremos la clase y al final voy a llamar la lista una vez que tengamos.
Ya, ahora sí empezaremos chicos. Para esta parte vamos a hacer lo siguiente, ya.
Voy a poner el pantalla, dame un ratito.
Ya, ahí.
Dame un ratito.
Ya, vámonos directamente, os voy a pasar al git.
Ya.
Para venir acá, evolution app, ya lo he subido hace ratito y vamos a hacer los siguientes
aspectos ya, así que voy a venir acá y les voy a pasar el link.
Listo, les estoy mandando ahorita mi small chat.
De mit, copian esa parte y directamente vayan descarreando.
Voy a hacer de dos maneras hoy día, no creo que tardemos mucho la clase ya que solamente
va a ser instalación y no, no voy a avanzar todavía ya que quisiera que todos tengan instalación
para el día sábado, pero voy a tratar de hacer los pasos correspondientes para lo que
esto lo logre ya. Entonces, lo que les acabo de enviar vayan haciendo un push o si no se
se hace un code, ya que dice doble ansip, hagan clic ahí y les va a descargar un archivo
comprimido. Ya ahorita les indico qué van a hacer con eso.
Ahí vayan, contin mando.
Ya, continuamos ahora así. Una vez que tengan eso, vamos a hacer lo siguiente,
lo van a descomprimir, van a abrirse una carpeta muy aparte. Yo les recomiendo que trabajen con
sus discos locales, es decir ahorita yo por ejemplo no tengo discos, solamente tengo un
disco central que es mi disco C. Si ustedes tienen otro disco, pueden meterlo ahí, ya,
pero si es que no pueden trabajar en su escritorio o en una carpeta específica. Yo voy a trabajar
por ejemplo en mi escritorio, voy a ir a la programación y ahí voy a crear una carpetita,
ya, esa carpetita le pueden llamar, no se depende de ese proyecto genérico en este caso.
Yo voy a colocar una carpetita y voy a colocar en este caso,
Evolution App, ya, Evolution.
Evolution. Ya, dentro de ahí van a llevar su comprimido y ahí lo van a descomprimir,
ya, aquí lo van a descomprimir ustedes. Yo lo voy a hacer contigo con ustedes para no tener,
que no tengan problemas, así que demos ratito. Voy a admitir a alguien más. Entonces una vez
que hayan regresado ahí, a ver, voy a admitir a alguien más. Ya, listo, voy a hacer lo que
usted decía, lo voy a descargar. Ya, vengo acá, voy a abrir esta parte.
Ya, esto lo voy a hacer control X y me lo voy a llevar a esa carpeta que acabo de
mostrar, sí, voy a admitir mi carpeta, voy a venir ahí, lo voy a descargar y lo voy a descomprimir.
Ya, acercó.
Pues va a aparecer este mensaje seguramente y lo extrae, ya.
Una vez que tengan eso, todo lo que está acá dentro chicos,
todo lo que está acá dentro, pueden cortarlo y pegarlo, o sea, control X y colocarlo todo acá,
para que no tenga un montón de carpetas creados. Ya, esto lo pueden eliminar y esto también lo
pueden eliminar. Ya, esos cuatro chicos tienen que estar ahí. Hasta les voy esperando.
Ya, de manjotito.
Una vez que tengan eso, vamos a lo siguiente.
Van a venir acá y van a abrir terminal. Dentro de su terminal pueden hacerlo con PowerShell o
Command Prom, o sea, CMD, no hay problema y una vez que tengan eso, los pasos que voy a hacer son
bastante largitos, así que traten de hacer pruebas hoy porque a la mayoría les va a ser
errores. Si no lo hacen prueba hoy, van a tener problemas luego para instalar o quizás sí o quizás
no. Así que traten de hacerlo junto con mi hoy día para que pueda ayudarlos a corregir, ya, porque
justamente no voy a poder ayudarles mañana y pasado, directamente os merezco la clase y aquí tengo
un viaje urgente y si es que lo hacen ahorita conmigo, normalmente lo podemos solucionar.
Ya, porque el sábado yo voy a programar un poco más rápido y quizás ya terminemos la clase de
la siguiente y la subsegúntica, o sea, de las cuatro clases que nos quedan tres clases,
de ahí empezarían con las defensas de sus proyectos. Ya, esa parte. Hasta ahí les espero,
vayan apresurándose los que se puedan y los que no, pues traten de hacer si o si la paso a paso,
lo que está en la vídeo que voy a mandar después de realmente. Ya, les voy a volver a enviar a
los que acaban de entrar el link. Ya, vamos a ver. Ya, voy a volver a estar en la masajaria de
mit, por si lo estoy volviendo a reenviar. Ahí entrense y vayan descargando code de un ansip
y eso vayan descomprimiendo en una carpeta que netamente no se conjuncen con sus otras
carpetas y que sea en este caso quizás mejor si estudie local, no es central, sino es el de él,
el que tengan directamente en eso. Ya, vayan haciendo este chico, pues yo los descomprimiendo
en una carpeta, netamente de mi escritorio, así que no hay problema si lo hacen así.
Visto, una vez que vayan descomprimiendo, ya van a empezar a procesar lo siguiente.
Ya, vuelvas a repetir esta parte. Vayan acá control, pero en su mouse, clic derecho,
abren terminal y van a colocar lo siguiente que voy a hacer. Ya, ahora antes de empezar esto,
ahora sí, ya tienen que haber tenido el docker. Vamos a ver docker, docker desktop.
Y ahí vamos a esperar. Todo esto va a tardar dos horas en instalarse. Así que en la mayor de los
casos, hasta 30 minutos, los que tienen veloz sistema, en 30 minutos, 20 minutos y hasta,
pero los que tienen baja latencia de red, así es un poquito largo. En mi caso,
está tardando una hora porque justamente al internet es muy malo, así que además el vecino no ha
pagado y en base a eso. Vayan a ver su desktop, tiene que estar funcionando antes de hacer lo que
voy a hacer. Ya, démonos un ratito. Ya, vayan haciendo ambos puntos para que todo funciona,
si no es nuevo a funcionar. Si es que no les funcionase, va a haber otra opción.
Ya.
Ya, no lo sé.
Bueno, hay que esperar un buen tiempo y así que tener paciencia por esta parte. Y una vez que
tengan eso, lo hacemos ejecutar acá. Si no, no todavía. Bueno, les explico un poquito antes,
aprovechando el tiempo, ¿no? Todo este aspecto me pregunté, ¿por qué docker? Generalmente,
evolution API para WhatsApp trabaja con docker. Ya, no sé, su mano derecha en los palabras.
Pues no lo trabajamos en otro entorno. Además, cuando trabajamos con un servidor en la 9,
ya pues sí o sí nosotros trabajamos con puro Linux y lo demás y esto y entra. O sea,
ya está por defecto incluso esto. Ya, no sé si han visto algunos que son de informáticos, igual
hay diplomados, maestrías, netamente en AWS, o servidores Linux, no, ahí entra más que
todo estos cosas. Pero como no estamos haciendo netamente local y posteriormente en la 9 que va
a haber una segunda versión, si es que la hay, ahí vamos a implementar algunas cosas. Pero ya está.
Ahora, yo hago un consejo, chicos, antes de empezar. Generalmente lo que voy a hacer yo,
en la mayoría de los casos, pues no sé, a ver, lo tengo en la cajita,
de web, los integrations, esto los va a aparecer algunas veces, ya. Y ahora estoy subiendo lo
AWS para lo que se arruinó. Ya, mientras tanto. Ahora sí, voy a parar esto un rato antes de empezar.
Y ahora vamos a lo siguiente entonces.
Podría pasar de nuevo la.
Listo, listo, listo, listo. Listo. Ya, ahorita lo se envía. Listo, ya lo se envía.
Listo, ahora sí ya pueden descargar los municipios listos. Bueno,
comentó los los siguientes. Generalmente, evolution API, si se trabaja con normal para
un negocio donde no tengamos mucha fluencia. A fluencia me refiero, ponganles que por día
puedan recibir más de mil, dos mil, bueno, arriba de 500 mensajes a diferentes números.
Ahí sí les van a detectar y ver si les dan diferentes tipos de baneos por 4, 6, 10, 12 horas,
24 horas. Pero si somos una empresa bastante legal, no creo que tengamos esa fluencia de gente de
por día. No es casi imposible tener esa cantidad de de ventas. Así que por eso es que es todo
es más aplicativo, más que todo, ámbitos corporativos de empresas medianas y bajas.
Ya empresas grandes, pero que tengan alta fluencia de usuarios como arriba de 500,
lo utilizan algunos este tipo de evolution APIs para hackear o para incluso de la cárcel
o de algún no sé, de algún clan más que todo de hackers, sí o sí utiliza esto a grosso modo y
cuando utiliza grosso modo pues se detectan. Por eso la mayoría de los hackers tienen
un montón de números aleatorios para poder detectar ales y hackearles. Ya, pero esto por
suerte tiene límites, o sea, les detectan y automáticamente el número se elimina o les dan
de baja. Por eso es que si es que ustedes lo van a utilizar para por día mayor a 500 usuarios,
no es recomendable. Sí o sí, ya se tiene que pagar lo que es, lo que hemos hecho anterior
clase que es WhatsApp API que es de Google, hay que pagar los tokens y demás para hacer los misos
procesos. Lo que hemos hecho anterior clase, voy a seguir continuando, pero quiero aprovechar esta
parte para que no nos atracemos mucho en la parte de instalación. Ese consejo les doy más que todo.
Así que procederemos. Ya, una vez que ya lo han hecho eso, ya es día de estar habilitar su Docker,
esconder un habilito a Docker. El mío ya tengo algunos, ya. Bueno, tengo unas imágenes,
algunas containers de los distintos proyectos, pero este caso, por ejemplo,
estos litros va a parecer a ustedes. A mí me parece porque yo tengo instalado,
pero no podemos ser con ustedes ahora. Puedo eliminarlo incluso para hacerlo con ustedes.
Va a haber, voy a tratar de eliminarlo para ejecutarlo.
Ya, le meteremos chicos, yo voy a eliminarlo y directamente.
Y vamos a ver con ustedes. Ya, así debe estar ustedes en la mayoría. Bueno, vacío.
Ahora se voy a empezar.
Una vez que han determinado esto, directamente vamos a hacer los siguientes pasos que les voy a
indicar. Les voy a pasar ahorita por Manuel, lo siguiente. Vamos a abrir nosotros en mede.
Y voy a hacer los siguientes consults. Vamos a hacer estos consultitas.
Y bueno, que te quiero que tengan. No tengan problemas con lo que les voy a mostrar.
Ejecuten esto. Nestat. Net. Net. Estat. Así. Tal cual.
Ya, este es lo que comando por secos.
Ya, este es el comando. Net. Estat. Espacio.
Listo. Eso me muestra todas las direcciones de mis PIPIDs que están funcionando, o sea,
los puertos que estoy manipulando. Por ejemplo, este de acá, fíjense. Este que es para mí está
ocupado. Está ocupado y generalmente Docker y, bueno, Evolution API utiliza este puerto.
Para comunicarse. Ya es como un número telefónico y nos la hablamos y nos puede
responder eso mismo. Y pues si no los los desarrollados la decimos. Está escuchando. Ya por ese puerto.
Pero en este caso de ustedes no debe estar. Porque utilizo aquí Apache y Spark. Así que de
ustedes no debe estar. Debe estar libre. Pero si es que no estuviese igual podemos solaparlo.
Pueden colocar lo siguiente. Algo más específico. Net. Así van a colocar. Net. Estat.
Espacio. En este caso vamos a colocar esta parte. Así el simbolito de este de acá que ven.
Ahora vamos a encontrar. Find. Esa tere. Ya. 80. 80.
Ya. Esta parte. Pero no voy a copiar. Yo voy a suscribir. Pasar.
Listo. Ya. Este puerto que estoy escuchando. Acá es lógico, ¿no? Porque aquí los hemos
echado el 80 80. Si es que no les aparece eso. En otros que les aparece el 80 80.
Acá que está escuchando. Fíjense. Mi pide es el 3.704. Y cuando le he buscado de manera
específica. Aquí está el 3.704. Ya. Pero yo quiero ver quién está en este caso.
Escuchándome. Así que voy a ejecutar esto. El task list. Find. En este caso es mi 704.
Listo. Ahí está ejecutándose este programa. Ya. Así que los voy a pasar este. Si es que
están utilizando ese aspecto. Lo he pasado en su enermit. Ya. Ese es el primero que pueden ejecutar.
Y en base a ese van a hacer este otro. Y van a copiar esto. Para ver quién está utilizando
ese puerto. Listo. Ya. Si está ahorita vamos a la par. Si no está, hagan lo mismo que lo que yo voy a
hacer. Ya. No hay problema. Mejor si no les aparece nada. Para evitar algún problema en el futuro.
Pero yo voy a trabajar en base como si estuviera trabajando con problemas. Ya. Ensemblaza de esta
parte. Vamos a empezar a trabajar. Se leyes. Se voy a colocar para borrar. Y empezaremos con el sistema.
Ya. Una vez que hayan tenido eso. Vamos a instalar en este caso lo que es Docker. Docker ya no
han instalado. Así que voy a irme directamente a la versión. Así que voy a consultar qué versiones
antes de empezar. Docker y versión. Perdón. Ya. Bueno, no hay problemas. Y bueno, me dar. Ya. Ahora
voy a hacer lo siguiente. Docker. Vamos a colocar esto más. Docker compose. Versión. Vamos a ver
qué versión tengo yo acá. 2.35.1. Bueno, me está antiguito. No sé. ¿Dónde usted se usa superior este?
Ya. Una vez que tengan eso, vamos a tratar de trabajar con los sistemas. Ahora. Una vez que
aquí les de esto arriba de 2.35. Este es el más aconsejable para el core Docker.
Vamos a hacer lo siguiente. Voy a abrir la termina que había abierto más antes cuando trabajaba
dentro de mi carpetita. Ahí voy a ejecutarlo. Para los que acaban de entrar, por ejemplo,
voy a volver a hacer roar y voy a abrir esto acá. A ver terminal y directamente aires va a aparecer.
Ya. Ahora sí. A partir de acá voy a tratar de empezar a trabajar con Docker. Así que estoy más o
menos espero para que no tengan problemas. Ya. En este caso voy a tratar de trabajar con Docker
compose y Docker sin haber. Ahora te los voy a mostrar esa parte. Ya. Con lo que vemos entonces.
Docker compose espacio app. Quión de así van a colocar. Si no les funciona ese guión de van a
hacerlo solamente con el app. Está ahí nomás. Ya. Yo voy a hacer con el app para que no tengan
problemas la mayoría. A veces cumplir con de para ver qué me da. Hacen enter y van a empezar a cargar.
Ya. Y se los va a crear rápidamente eso. Ya está. De ustedes seguramente va a tardar un poco.
Ya. De usted va a tardar bastante. Que es veinte minutos, media hora, dos horas. Mucho va a depender
de la de la capacidad de su computadora como tanto de la internet. Voy a ejecutar a Docker compose sin
de. Ya. Y esto es lo que les tiene que aparecer.
Está tratando de conectar a pos. Y está tratando de generarse crearse la tabla de base de datos.
Ahora qué está haciendo acá. El bueno contenedor acá se está creando dentro del
contenedor lo que es la conexión con la base de datos. Para qué para que futuro ya me pueda grabar
números, grabar citas, grabar todo acá dentro de la configuración. Ya. Ahora no se van a
asustar. Va a parar tus errores. Es decir, esto internamente se va hackeando y hackeando en
bucles hasta lograr la conexión con la base de datos. Esto puede tardar mucho o puede tardar muy
poco. En este caso, la primera vez que hagan va a tardar bien rápido porque no no utilizan
ustedes programas para que vaya enchocando haciendo reconversión de valores en mascarando
criptografía. No lo hace. Pero en mi caso, como lo he borró y lo estoy volviendo a ejecutar,
va a empezar a analizar todo eso. Ya y está empezando a crear las migraciones correspondientes
para generarme. Hay que esperar.
Y hasta creo a ver si está conectando mi sistema y me tiene que lanzar una cheta de
p. Pero ya está en sí. Ya está terminando y está conectando y está volviendo a entrar.
Está empezando a inicializar o levantar lo que es la evolución API.
Y ahí está. Fíjense acá. Por ejemplo, aquí me dice que está terminando. No está terminando
pero ya está corredible a levantar mi HTTP 8080. Este es el puerto que les había comentado que trabaja.
Ya esa parte, si te chicos, va a tardar un montón era o va a tardar un rápido.
Lo hace muy rápido en este caso. Para ver si está instalado bien hasta que les debo
te hasta acá. Esta cosa verde que ven acá hasta ahí vamos a abrir un nuevo navegador.
En este caso mi navegador va a ser el local 7777. Ya van a colocar entonces local hosts
7777 y van a petrante. Les tendría que aparecer esto.
Ya. Y si nos damos cuenta me dice. Ah, no anda tal manager me dice y el manager me está dando
una o nueva o URL. Aquí está. Eso voy a copiarme. Ojo, siempre y cuando haya llegado hasta acá.
Ya tiene que aparecer tal cual como están viendo. Eso significa que ya se ha conectado a todo la base
de datos, ha conectado a sí mismo y está levantando. Directamente para trabajar. Ya ahora si entramos
antes al docker de esto miren ya se instalado. Y si hago esta partecita clica.
Dice que mi postgres y mi evolución API están funcionando por su medalla los interfaces
verdes y te dice que mi puerto se localhost 7777 por eso es que ingresado acá a ese puerto y me
tendría que votar esto. Una vez que hago eso copio y voy a abrir acá.
Y esta parte les va a aparecer así. Es la interfaz general de evolución API.
Ya ahora que hay que colocar a piquí. Esta piquí hasta dentro del proyecto. Si nos
nos vamos acá en acá mismo donde están hecho y la la conversión y donde han
y descomprimido se les va a crear estas tres instancias evolución intancia evolución postgres
y es el store. Ya van a abrir ustedes el evolución punto en vez hacen clic derecho y lo van a abrir
con eso con un blog de notas. Abre el blog de notas va a aparecer esto.
Aquí está toda la información y dónde tenemos que hacer y demás y acá abajo.
Aquí dice autentication API piquí dice aquí está esta parte ustedes pueden cambiar la
ya su clave secreta de ustedes no hay problema yo no voy a cambiar
porque esto voy a copiar y lo voy a pegar acá
y lo voy a hacer el login. Si se han dado cuenta y he podido ingresar a
bueno a la API ya este instanche me sirve para instanciar lo que son los números así puedo
colocar aquí la instancia que se llama milton y trabajemos con algunos modelos ya unos canales
en los palabras hay tres canales hay bailaris el whatsapp api el evolución generalmente para
trabajar de manera no tan legal pero para que esto es como se ve comentas rato no no
los aquí ni en sus usuarios normales o funcional bailing pero este whatsapp clave api ya pueden
trabajar con su clout de lo que pueden comprarse de meta ya estos dos de acá por ejemplo esto
igual trabajamos acá directamente así de manera ilegal se podría decir pero no es ilegal sino
es que para aspectos de marketing si se lo ve ilegal pero yo me trabaja con el bailing y aquí
que loca en el número de ustedes siempre coloque en el 591 con como adelante y su número de
whatsapp business whatsapp normal pero supongo que la mayor de su business pero acá en este caso
consejo verbos repetibles si es que van a manejar arriba de 500 usuarios yo no les aconsejo
que coloquen sus números ya pueden trabajar con los números de empresa porque les van a
vanear pero no creo no hay negocio que yo conozca excepto las dos restaurantes y algunas empresas
que venden por delivery pero que administran por whatsapp ahí si son más de 500 usuarios ahí
si les pueden vanear siempre y cuando el sistema vuelva a petiles no les detecte que es marketing
ya es que más refiero con marketing no sé si en alguna vez algún grupo al entrado ustedes
y siempre les mandan de criptografía de binance de bitcoins que este tipo de mensajes si les detecta
eso si es se podría decir si bueno nosotros decimos los virus informáticos pero de marketing en este
caso los crashing pero no creo que ustedes lo utilicen ya pero por si acaso se aconsejo si
nos van a vanear los van a bajar la cuenta y demás si están trabajando con una empresa que es
bastante de tiempo y ya no tiene ese mismo número bastante tiempo cuidado que les que les hagan
problemas eso es la primera parte hasta aquí debería de funcionar a todos porque nunca han
trabajado con otro tipo de programas para que se les vaya solapando y eso es bien complicado
de deshacer y volver a hacer otros instancias una vez que tengan ahí ya estaría terminado el proyecto
a partir de acá netamente es conexiones y delas hay otra forma si es que les va a dar
esos de esa parte les enseñará pero la que voy a enseñar les hablará no debería de no deberían
aplicarlo porque con esto ya sufi pero les voy a enseñar igual para que se crean sus propios
contenedores en esta parte por si acaso lo que acabo de hacer acá todo esto todo esto netamente
chicos es tiene un tiempo de vida no nomás refiero que vaya a dejar de funcionar si no es que
si quieren creer proyectos nuevos y demás y propios netamente así ya pueden hacer usted sea
normal pero tiene otro proceso es lo que voy a hacer ahorita esto lo que se ha pasado es eterno
si pero alguien quizá me quiera hacer prueba pide más así que esa parte lo vamos a hacer ya no con
esto ya pero lo otro es más para subirlo a la nube así que lo haremos y a ver creme otro ya
recomendación no hagan lo que voy a hacer si es que no lo funcionan van a chocar y van a tener
problemas si es que las a funcionado la primera normal voy a crear mucho carpeta voy a colocar
evolución ya
listo voy a entrar en acá y voy a empezar a crear ya en esta casa voy a colocar lo siguiente por
ejemplo no va a terminar
ahí van a estar y voy a empezar a crear mechos ya pero que voy a trabajar con visor de code
y esto
yo
y a lo que voy a creerme son cuatro cuatro folders ya pueden crearlo por consola pueden crearlo
directamente por de manera gráfica directamente acá voy a colocar en este caso un file
docker compos
punto y ml listo
listo esperamos ahí
y a esta parte por si a casi igual tarde ya pero se plan veces que no les funcionan ningún
esto sabe tener 15 minutos en el peor de los casos
otro día crame el debe punto m que es mi base de datos no se va a guardar todos mis
informaciones luego voy a crame un evolución punto nv y luego voy a crame un
para escolar que se vaya a mi gt y si tal cual ya listo
así en esta parte del nv voy a hacer lo siguiente
si no me acuerdo o si me recuerdo ahorita que lo sé
evolución
ahora por si acaso esto tiene ya sus pases si si es que no se se no se recuerdo ahorita no me
recuerdo pueden hacer acá de volución hay perdón
y a ponerse acá y aquí está en evolución el pie documentación van a colocar sin los
ya no solamente pueden trabajar con posiles ya vamos a saber tardar de un reto
puede trabajar con otros entornos de base de datos no es obligatorio trabajar con eso
ya aquí está
puede trabajar como es y cual con demás aspectos de api ya
llevando con compos
no se integración ya voy a irme a
y aquí está por si acaso todo
ya toda la documentación
para poder hacer las instalaciones por responder solamente tiene que tomar el
tiempo y el literal de leer bastante y instalaciones por ejemplo ya aquí está
docker se se dan cuenta aquí están las últimas versiones de ok ver docker y docker compos y
a los mínimos y aquí pueden clonar aquí está justo lo que les estoy ahorita creando
todo esto está todos podemos copiar y pegar uno más aquí está bien post los datos de
esa evolución de v pues es el ser un empeor secret password y aquí lo mismo ahí está todo lo que
voy a hacer ahorita es que voy a copiar y voy a pegar nomás y aquí por ejemplo donde dice
docker compos y a y a m o y a m l no importa mucho eso todos estos problemas copiar y pegar no hay
problema aquí es donde ustedes tienen que cambiar sus passwords de usuario pero que les ha pasado
automáticamente y a los a creado ustedes de que no van a tener problema y también se puede trabajar
con instalaciones de npm pero por tipo de instancias y que hay para mac los que tienen mac y aquí
otros dos hay un montón de las de cosas que pueden trabajar aquí está maya se cuide configuración
como se instala tanto en windows en linux en mac todo está ahí
y a todos estoy hasta con lo que les ha pasado ahora sí volveremos al medio del asunto
voy a copiarme estas partes y te sé
me ha gustado
de menudo chico que está
voy a copiarme esto
voy a venir a mí acá
listo y a pegar yo y aquí pueden colocar diferente tipo de bueno username y demás hay otro más más
compacto por ejemplo en vez de trabajar con base de datos podemos trabajar con igual evolución
nomás que se llama también evolución evolución de media pero ya pueden ver ustedes ahí para que
no se ve con los anteriores tratan de darles siempre numeritos por ejemplo yo voy a colocar dos
cuatro seis pero siempre me morís en ceso ya el pasbo también traten de darse un pasbo que ustedes
pueden ejecutar ya por ejemplo voy a dar evolución igual uno dos tres
ya y en username déjanlo con pósfilos nomás ya o incluso a que lo pueden cambiar y lo pueden ser
evolución
y listo ya eso ya dependen de ustedes ahora voy a buscarme el otro el evolution punto en y
ya vamos a irnos acá aquí debe estar aquí está todo esto se copian
y en acá y lo pegan
otro les igual esto ya luego que nos necesitamos el ya ya aquí de
usted ya carriba este bueno
ya tenemos eso las instancias aquí está se copian esto igual lo crean acá
ya control es para guardarlo y ahora vamos a irnos directamente a lo que es la fase del
el git no es necesario automáticamente se genera esto ahora lo mismo
esta parte vayan cambiando si se dan cuenta todo esto es idéntico esto
entonces vamos a tener que copiarlo y pegarlo acá
y
listo ahí pueden pegarlo directamente nada más ya esta parte aumenten eso y hagan el así tal
cual para que no los tenga de que tengan problemas supuestamente ya yo no lo voy a hacer todavía
porque ya tengo un estrado no me quiero generar problemas interno así que prefiero no trabajar
todavía para estos por el caso para los que no no les está corriendo con este tipo de
ejemplos y demás ya
listo en su la vez que tengan hasta ahí que más pueden cambiar esta partecito
todo esto dejen lo por defecto
esto también dejen lo por defecto
si si todo ahora los que tienen problemas con el puerto
si ahorita no les ha corrido por los motivos y es decir algún puerto que está mal
aquí pueden cambiarlo en vez de 80 81
o el 82 o el 83
una vez que ya hemos hecho todo eso o sea siempre es hacemos lo mismo que hemos hecho anterior
o sea en la carpeta que he creado en la nueva
directamente acá ahora que estoy ahorita no acá lo mismo clic derecho
abren terminar
y de nuevo van a colocar docker compose así docker compose
espacio y onde y listo lo crean entre y lo mismo que hemos hecho eso otros
nada más ya eso es en caso de que tengan problemas
pero no lo vamos a trabajar así porque creo que lo medio debe tener normal
normal ya eso es un más que todo necesito chicos hasta la si hasta el día sábado
para que podamos empezar a hacer proyectos un poquito más estructurados ya a la primera
les va a funcionar no creo que nadie tenga problemas porque es de manera directa ya esa
parte si de chicos ahora si
una vez que ya hemos hecho eso pues ya podemos en este caso llamar lista
y en base a la lista que os voy a mostrar vas a hacer defensa ya hoy día los voy a dar los grupos
bueno grupos van a trabajar independientemente
así que
aprovecharemos esa parte
y
listo
me voy a sortear
y en base a esto pues vamos a ya tener defensas
son 16 como son cuatro días de dissertación a partir de la fecha por si acaso tenemos
apague mi computadora
y hoy estamos 18 ya a ver vamos a hacer los carcados necesarios nos queda cuatro clases
el sábado 20 jueves 25 sábado 27 y el último clases sería jueves 2 ya incluso probablemente
vamos a terminar sábado 27 terminamos las clases ya se el 27 y es el 2
inmediatamente el 4 el 9 el 11 y el 16 son las defensas
ya voy a intentar de copiar este ratito para que nos perdamos tenemos ratito voy a hacer un scream y
los voy a colocar acá
ya creo que no puedo hacer scream tenemos retito
y en base a eso ya van a tener sus fechas de desertación
ahora sí creo
nunca son casas y a eso voy a colocar acá
ahora sí
y a de nueve nos repartiremos y a grupos y va a ser en base a lo que han mandado
en la lista
ya nos quedamos en lo siguiente
primer grupo
segundo grupo
tercer grupo
y cuarto grupo
ya no están obligados a asistir esos días chicos ya directamente el día de su exposición
nada más ya voy a aceptar los cuatro y luego el siguiente clase de ellos y ellos y ellos ya
entonces para que seamos justos ellos seguramente han llenado primeritos ya van a pasar al último
así que la el orden de defensa va a ser el siguiente
listo ahí pari
ya ahora sí
listo este primer grupo en exponer segundo tercero cuarto
ya ese es el orden
la fecha para ellos
fecha aquí voy a notar asistencia partir de anterior crecio estoy notando porque lo voy a notar con
ustedes si el rey llama lista asistencia 18 0 6 20 26 listo vamos a colocar luego en este caso
estamos el 18 luego tenemos el 20 0 6 20 26 y así sucede una dos tres hasta aquí pasaríamos
ya quedaremos bien ya probablemente si es que no terminó hasta el 27
bueno termina el 2 pero lo más probable es que terminamos el 27 así que
25 0 6 20 26 y directamente
perdón perdón perdón se que me voy a colocar y ahora sí y por último 27
y aquí empezarían las defensas y esto es asistencia asistencia y asistencia
ya estos de certación ya el primer grupo empezaría
netamente el 2 de julio
y
es la primera defensa anotense la fecha porque es 98 por ciento probable que lo defienden ese día
ya me veo un poquito y los demás ya van y sucesivamente obviamente
ya entonces siguiente grupo va a ser el perdón estamos tres no el cuatro sería su siguiente
0 4 0 7 20 20 esto perdón esto es el 7
listo y por último el siguiente grupo va a ser obviamente el 9 y el 11 respectivamente
ya ya y terminaríamos las clases ese día bueno las clases no es la
de este aspecto ese día
y ya no habría más procesos listo si alguien falta ahorita en la lista puede hablar
ya que están todos en el dinero yo pasa que no puede
hacerlo el formulario que se me cortó esa esa clases no cortó el fallo y no puede
tenía cinco días y ahora si ya vamos a quedar contigo ya unite al grupo número uno ya cual es tu nombre
ay perdón tu visa
listo gracias miguel
si
res lo es lo hizo miguel listo yo te voy a notar ahí
sé llenar el formulario
eso la verdad me ha estado mucho trabajo
pero es tu nombre
son brabalos
listo
listo van a ser el primer grupo entonces
si ahora vamos a hablar ahorita ahorita os voy a acomodar
vemos ratito
y estos bien otras sus nombres ya bien pero quedaremos bien
y entonces no creo que nos alcance mucho tiempo
ya vamos a hacer lo siguiente
todos ellos
que día cae pues un miércoles no no es una pero el dos jueves la media jueves no tiene tiempo
ya
ruiz te vas a pasar te mantienes ahí sandra te vas al grupo verde
al grupo verde del grupo número dos listo bueno si ya alguien más
no todos están ya todos están entonces chicos los 18 estaríamos y yendo directamente a defensa
con la embajada ya hasta hoy día tenemos que quedar eso y hasta quedado si alguien falta pues no
dudan hablar ahorita mismo antes que envíe las listas oficiales ya bueno vaya mal lista si están
duditos si no están vamos a sacarlos ya bien mal y en base eso antes de eso voy a secar las
los screams de ahí de morratito
y en base eso vamos a quedar ya bueno aquí mismo lo que aguarda los screens para los clases correspondientes
ya siguiente voy a dejar de compartir y voy a empezar a llamar listo ya
de monroto chicos
ya
de monroto estoy anotando los participaciones y las
listo ya no se empezamos a llamar listo
los demás cuatro clases y muchos ya da valor y aliso
ya no hay ríbar a coimbra está
rascanda listo gracias ramos castro
presente listo al barber de quispe
maria veran no hay cuento to rico
no hay serrano velozco
hay a la arias
listo gracias menchaca araus
esto vida lurquiza
listo lópez vizaga
listo callejás camargo
ya no hay hay creo no hay
no hay valdes vargas
no hay serrantes mamá no ya gracias valdes
serrantes listo y hasta serrantes mamá
monica patricia listo gracias luis agar rubín
no hay
vaca perera
no hay tanto
salinas y baños
salinas y bañas
si que te lo que tal rubín de
ella listo listo listo gracias salinas y bañas está madeline
y ahora ya pasó a mi
vaya listo
riz loisa miguel ahí estaba y ahora lo son de esta listo
riberos despulcan los asipas
riberos
a valdivia solo valerias no?
si
ya listo listo gracias
ya eh taten de existir las cuatro clases que nos queda
ya que algunas personas no solamente no notó todo el nombre creo y no nos
existió ninguna clase o pocas clases así que vamos a eliminarlos
pero taten de existir las últimas cuatro clases hasta el 27 y ahí terminamos ya
ya directamente sus exorcisiones y demás
y este chico cosas hasta el sábado porfa taten de instalar todo ese aspecto
si tienen problemas me dicen internamente pero no creo que tengan problemas
así que el sábado mismo voy a empezar a avanzar todo de manera corrida ya
y este chico sino hay preguntas ahí terminamos la clase
pueden retirar
o toma un metito porfa ya listo esto va a haber
los puedes retirarse chicos no hay problema
nos vemos la siguiente clase
eje lo subirá hasta hasta noche si si
tarde la el vídeo ahorita mejor voy a subir porque como es cortito no hay problema
si si ya listo listo gracias listo chucho ahorita voy a dejar de que pueda
no chucho